I don't think he understood what he was
doing he liked talking to big guys you
know the big guys get together and they
do big guy things but you did accept it
for 17 months didn't you why so long the
principal way you remove presidents is
by elections mad by impeachment four
months to go to the presidential
elections in America Donald Trump is
sinking in the polls and now his former
national security adviser says he isn't
fit to be President anyway in a new book
John Bolton a long-serving big beast of
the Republican Party accuses mr. trummer
the litany of incompetence and
obstruction of justice mr. Bolton is my
guest this week from Washington how much
damage have Trump and Bolton done to
America and the rest of the world
[Music]
john bolton welcome to conflict zone i
had to be with you thank you for having
when you became donald trump's national
security adviser you wrote that you
thought you knew what you were getting
yourself into if that's true why work
for and give your loyalty to a man
labeled as a serial liar
well i viewed the loyalty that i owed
and that i tried to live up to to the
constitution in the country you know
we're not a medieval society you don't
have a liege lord that you Oh personal
loyalty to it's not the Mafia or
something like that and the fact was in
my view the country faced some serious
challenges I think a number of national
security policies during the Obama
administration had been misguided there
was a chance to make a contribution I
certainly went in with my eyes open but
I believed at least at that time that we
could have a more regular process and
more typical if you will
Republican administration and
notwithstanding the risks I thought they
were worth taking and the risks did they
include the honesty and integrity of the
President or lack of it didn't that
matter to you well it it remained to be
seen as far as I was concerned how much
of this was campaign rhetoric by the
opposition I had had as I recount in the
book a number of conversations with
Donald Trump before the election during
the transition in his first year in
office we talked about all of my views
on the key issues he had watched me on
Fox News for nearly 10 years I assumed
he was listening to what I was saying I
certainly wasn't shy about sharing my
views and therefore when we talked about
working together and and the the role of
the national security adviser it struck
me it was entirely possible that that we
could work together and
issues of his character would not
adversely affect the decision-making on
national security issues but she was
naive I don't I don't think I was naive
and and I thought it could be as as many
others did who came to work for the
administration that it could be made
successful now the book really is the
story of whether that turned out to be
true or not
obstruction of justice is perhaps your
most serious charge against Trump you
talked about several episode where he
expressed a willingness to halt criminal
investigations to in effect give
personal favors to dictators he liked to
the Turkish leader reject type our Diwan
even to Xi Jinping anyone else well I
think these these were the most obvious
but the the whole concept of dealing for
example with Vladimir Putin as if the
assertions of our intelligence services
were the moral equivalent of what Putin
said on behalf of Russia well it was
another aspect of it and I felt that
this was an extremely serious defect in
Trump's performance on the
investigations of hawk bagged CTE Huawei
and others spoke with the counsel to the
president spoke with the Attorney
General really that's their domain to
take a look at and I say in the book
that they were troubled by it that this
is the this is the Ukraine case that
everybody's familiar with that was the
kind of last issue that I dealt with
before I resigned it's become the most
famous but my point really was it was
only one in a series Trump's patent you
said looked like obstruction of justice
as a way of life which you said we
couldn't accept but you could accept it
for 17 months didn't you why so long
well you know a pattern by definition is
something that does
emerge all at once and the the personal
dilemma that anybody in a senior
position faces is the knowledge that
you're not going to prevail on every
issue I like to say I was the national
security adviser not the national
security decision-maker in each of these
cases as they came up I had
conversations with others in the
administration I certainly didn't feel
that I was alone in my view of of the
seriousness of these issues but I think
it's a very personal decision to try and
decide when finally you have to resign
versus whether you can keep to keep
doing what you're trying to do because
of the issues presented you say you
shared your concerns about this pattern
of obstruction with key members of
trumps inner team
the Attorney General Bill Barr Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo you say bar told
you he was very worried about the
appearances Trump was creating just the
appearances is that all that worried him
well look at the reason I informed him
and the White House Counsel Patsy
Bologna and others was because they're
the ones responsible for enforcing the
legal guidelines and boundaries let me
finish for a second it's not my job to
be the prosecutor it's my job to tell
the people whose responsibility it is
what I was saying and and let them
decide what to do the fact that I didn't
know what they were doing didn't
surprise me and the fact is we don't
know what yet may be going on you know
it's very easy for somebody who's never
been in this kind of circumstance
to just announce their moral purity and
stand out and virtue signal my view is
that
that that in in service to the country
that that there are a lot of factors to
be taken into account and the the duty
that one owes to the Constitution faced
with this kind of president isn't simply
to make yourself feel good by by by
issuing virtuous piety but really more
by trying to get the right thing done so
it to take the example of Ukraine my
focus was on getting the security
assistance to Ukraine the trunk was
holding up to get that delivered and if
that finally succeeded as it turned out
the day after I resigned but that is the
focus I think that that in my job was my
responsibility I told several members of
the NSC staff to speak to the lawyers to
told them what we had seen and they did
that that fulfilled their
responsibilities and and I thought that
was the proper course the officials you
alerted to Trump's obstruction of
justice what conclusion did you draw
from their lack of any substantive
reaction that Trump had successfully
corrupted the government machine and
made it live for him well I think it's
it's pretty evident that the the number
of people in inside the government who
were willing to challenge Trump on a
number of these issues has diminished
over time now let me be clear the
president holds the constitutional
responsibility you can like that or not
like that but the Constitution is very
clear if you don't want to carry out an
order the responsible thing to do is to
resign and if others in the government
are not carrying out their
responsibilities that that's a matter
for them and their conscience and how
they see their job what is it about
dictators and despots that Trump so
admires did he ever tell you no and I'm
not a shrink I don't psychoanalyze
people
I think others others like to do that
and God bless him if that's what they
wanted to do I think the Trump in a
sense envied the Xi Jinping's and the
and the Vladimir Putin's he liked
talking to big guys you know big guys
get together and they do big guy things
I think it was that simplistic I didn't
see any evidence of a relationship that
would be improper or constitute undue
influence I just think that was part of
Trump's simple simplistic view of the
relations with foreign leaders
especially authoritarian foreign leaders
let's take the North Korean leader Kim
jong-un you were present at two out of
three meetings between Trump and Kim you
said there were times when we were very
close to making concessions that I think
even prior administrations like the
Clinton and Obama administrations
wouldn't have made was Trump willing to
give away the shop what kinds of
concessions do you mean well I don't
think he understood what he was doing I
think he he he longed for a deal with
North Korea on the nuclear weapons
program I don't think he studied the
issue closely enough to know what the
ramifications of different terms that
were offered were I think ultimately in
the case of the Hanoi summit the second
meeting where he did walk away from a
proposal by North Korea that I thought
entirely inadequate he did so because he
knew that if he were to have accepted it
it would have produced a volcanic
political reaction in America from the
Republican Party and that he
fundamentally couldn't do that and that
really was the sort of reaction that
troubled me the most that he didn't
approach North Korea or much else on the
basis of philosophy or grand strategy or
policy he approached it on the basis of
what was politically beneficial to him
now look every democratic politician in
whatever country takes politics into
account in their
decision-making it goes with the
territory it's not only not something to
be surprised at it would be surprising
if they didn't take politics into
account the difference with Trump is
qualitative it's the it's not just a
factor in decision-making on serious
issues sometimes it seemed to me to be
essentially the only factor he took into
account a lot has been made of Trump's
supine attitude to Vladimir Putin his
unwillingness to raise difficult issues
like election interference his Trump
scared of him you know I don't think
he's scared of him and and at Helsinki
to be clear Putin himself said at the
lunch after the one-on-one meeting the
two of them had that it was Trump who
had raised the election interference
issue I think it's very important for
people who observe Trump who have to
make decisions on whether to vote for
him or people who report on him to be
accurate in their criticisms there's
plenty to criticize but when people
stretch beyond what they need to to make
the criticism it doesn't strengthen the
case against Trump it weakens it
emboldened many of his supporters to say
we're victims of a conspiracy by the
press or whatever fake news hoaxes that
sort of thing so when you have Vladimir
Putin saying the Trump raised the
election interference issue at the
Helsinki summit I think that's worth
taking into account if you want to
criticize drunk I did but be accurate
about it there are no detailed records
according to Washington Post no detailed
records from five of trumps meetings
with Putin since taking office and that
on at least one occasion in Hamburg in
2017 he asked for the interpreters notes
and ordered him to say nothing about the
discussion which does indicate doesn't
it that Trump had something to hide from
these discussions I don't know what it
indicates I wasn't in the government in
2017 I can
you in the case of the Helsinki meeting
NSC staff did speak with our interpreter
and and got a pretty complete readout of
of what the two leaders discussed which
turned out to be mostly on Syria mostly
Putin talking you know I think that
Trump is very mistrustful of of not only
the bureaucracy as a whole but but even
his own staff I think it reflects the
way he did business in the Trump
Organization and I think one of his
problems as president is that he still
hasn't fully appreciated what it means
to be president of the United States as
opposed to the head of the Trump
Organization how credible is trumps
claim not to have been briefed about
reports that the Russians paid the
Taliban to kill American soldiers you
were national security adviser in March
last year when this information
apparently surfaced well there have been
press reports to that effect then you
know press reports are sometimes wrong
and in any event I have said repeatedly
I'm not going to comment on that because
it doesn't intelligence I can say with
respect to the information reported
about this issue in 2020 that it's
surprising to me that it wasn't briefed
to the president the administration
itself has apparently said it was in the
presidential Daily Brief during my 17
months at the White House I never saw
any evidence that the president read the
PDB and in terms of whether or not it
was briefed to him I've said and I think
it's important for people to understand
that I agreed with Susan Rice who has
written an op-ed where she said if she
were national security adviser and that
information had come to her attention
she'd have gone in to the Oval Office
and told a Barack Obama and I like to
think I would have done the same do you
buy the story which has been put out by
your successor as National Security
Advisor Robert O'Brien who said the
president's career CIA briefer decided
not to brief him about this because it
was unverified intelligence she made
that call
I think she made the right cold does the
system work like that well it didn't
work like that when I was there in order
to work like that under my predecessor
HR McMaster at least as I understand it
the the issue when you only provide an
oral briefing to the president twice a
week is how much are you going to try
and squeeze in a limited amount of time
and that's usually discussed at a
preliminary meeting right before going
in to see the president with the
Director of National Intelligence the
director of the CIA the briefer of the
time and and myself you know it would be
better if the president read the
materials and studied them more
carefully I think that that written
materials tend to be a more efficient
way to convey information certainly the
president's always free to ask questions
and that's to be encouraged but it's
it's despite what some advisors to the
president have said he does not consume
as much intelligence as he should let's
talk if we may about the 2018 murder of
the Saudi journalist Jamarcus Auggie by
Saudi operatives in Istanbul October the
15th that year Trump decided to stand by
the Saudi leadership and even wrote
their excuse for them suggesting it was
a rogue operation but it wasn't a rogue
operation was it well you know I'm not
going to get into the to the the
intelligence that the United States had
on that I can say the president decided
that he was going to stand by the Saudis
and because of the importance of the
relationship if that position I think
was was in a way verified by Vladimir
Putin in a conversation I had with him
in Moscow who said look you don't want
to sell weapons to the Saudis you don't
have to I'd be happy to sell it to them
is that what it really comes down to
who's going to be able to sell weapons
to whom you gave a free pass to a
government that brazenly chops up its
political opponents in other people's
countries and not just to the Saudis but
to every other
state the US does big business with the
tortures and murders its own people
doesn't that worry you well you know as
Winston Churchill said if if the devil
were to have opposed Adolf Hitler he
would have found that in his heart for a
kind word to Satan on the floor of the
House of Commons you don't you don't
always get to pick who your allies are
in a difficult unstable part of the
world nobody in the administration
condoned what happened to Khashoggi
there's no question about it but we live
in a harsh world you live in a world
where i wonder how many of the untold
masses jailed for having opinions in
Saudi Arabia and other despotic states
that the u.s. befriends would go along
with your statement that the greatest
hope for freedom of mankind is the u.s.
if a country that can finesse mr.
Khashoggi murder is the best hope for
mankind's freedom then god help mankind
No
well look you're entitled to your
opinions I'm glad and proud to be an
American citizen
there isn't any country in the world
that has done more to protect human
freedom than the United States period
close quote let's talk about Iran if we
may so many bad deals to kill you once
wrote so little time the one that you
really had in your sights over many
years was the Iran nuclear deal wasn't
it unenforceable men you better want
unenforceable you called it I'm
verifiable and inadequate in duration
and scope but you wanted to kill that
deal with nothing to put in its place
over the objections of key members of
Israel's military and intelligence staff
who regard 'iron as their number-one
adversary many of them didn't see it
your way did they well I think you have
it wrong about Israel I think support
for the u.s. getting out of the Iran
nuclear deal in Israel is overwhelming
you may have noticed some things are
happening in Iran they're centrifuge
assembly plant at Natanz apparently had
a severe accident that that they've not
revealed fully there are other
oceans going on around the country I
don't know who's doing it but I'm glad
somebody's doing it I don't know whether
it's the precursor to taking down the
entire nuclear weapons and ballistic
missile program in Iran but it certainly
is a step in that direction the fact is
I don't trust the ayatollahs and the
regime I think they consistently
withheld information from international
inspectors they lied about the nature of
the program for 20-plus years until they
were caught time and time again in those
lies I don't think they ever made a
strategic decision to give up nuclear
weapons and I think the u.s. decision to
pull out of the deal
caught them by surprise and left them in
a very difficult position it's a hugely
unpopular regime in Iran and hopefully
the day will come when the ayatollahs
are swept into the dustbin of history if
we can just go back to Ukraine you
decided not to give testimony at the
house impeachment hearing you didn't
like the way the Democrats handled the
process you called it impeachment
malpractice if you thought the president
was abusing his power wasn't it more
important to get that out than worrying
about procedural issues isn't it more
important to get a result again you're
back in the virtues signaling posturing
mode of politics and and that's just not
the way I do things the Democratic
malpractice which is what it was left
the situation worse than it was before
the impeachment why because the way they
conducted the impeachment in a very
partisan fashion essentially guaranteed
a partisan outcome and the outcome was
that the Senate acquitted Trump so the
impeachment advocates said that by the
house action of impeaching the president
he will be deterred from engaging in the
kind of conduct we saw in Ukraine but
they had no way of getting 2/3 of the
Senate to vote to convict
so having acquitted Trump they they
don't only did not deter him they
empowered him they
moved the impeachment guardrail is a
huge mistake by publishing this book
what I've done is to try and lay the
facts out before the real judges not
Congress but the American people we have
an election in four months the American
people will speak I trust their judgment
more than Congress but the election
isn't a substitute for the
constitutional provisions for removing a
president from office what do you think
elections are if they're not the
principle constitutional path to doing
just that
impeachment has occurred four times in
American history and no president has
ever been convicted only Nixon resigned
and what distinguishes the Watergate
impeachment proceeding from the three
that failed Andrew Johnson Bill Clinton
and Donald Trump
the Democrats worked in Watergate with
Republican Sam Ervin of North Korea
North Carolina worked with Howard Baker
of Tennessee and they produced a growing
feeling on a bipartisan basis that Nixon
had to go by ignoring that relatively
recent precedent the Democrats
guaranteed the outcome we got the and
this this is a I think a very
fundamental point about democratic
theory the principled way you remove
presidents is by elections not by
impeachment we're four months away from
the next of those elections
what if Trump loses by a small margin do
you expect him to go quietly or organize
some kind of bizarre national emergency
to try and stay where he is well maybe
you would tell me what evidence you have
that he's planning to create a bizarre
national emergency you know Arizona didn
t that the the votes will be the most
corrupt election in the history of our
country and we cannot let this happen so
you're making the same mistake as many
Trump critics you're exaggerating
without adequate evidence and I know
your question I know from your questions
you obviously despise Trump that that's
fine I understand that but but the way
you're approaching it makes it difficult
for those of us who are opposed to him
getting another term to make the case to
Americans who want to know what the
facts are that that's something but you
know the the people will decide here in
four months and we'll see what the
outcome is before you get hyperthyroid
about it let's see what happens John
Bolton thanks very much for being on
conflict zone I enjoyed it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]